so innovation is a super hot topic right
everywhere I don't know a single
organization that innovation isn't on
its ten strategic objectives of the next
year but how do you innovate where is
the source of innovation where do you
seek inspiration those are questions
that are largely mysteries to most
people what this course aims to do is
basically clear out some of that mystery
so that the topics covered are to sort
of core disciplines to design thinking
and good design process prototyping and
empathy work
and empathy is really the idea that you
need to profoundly understand your
customer or your user at a very personal
level understand their emotional
motivations understand their needs and
gain some insight into their life and
what matters to them and to do that we
use some techniques which really involve
directly getting out and interacting
with customers and in particular going
very very deep on interview techniques
and the kinds of questions and
interviews that will elicit responses
about what matters to them in their
lives what kind of needs they actually
have that that your business or
organization can can solve that
hopefully your competitors are not
seeing because you're the one out
gaining empathy and so this course is
really it's all about understanding
people but understanding people in the
service of meeting business objectives
so often in business we we sort of seek
to validator ideas before we actually
build them we think of the prototype is
something that happens after we've built
a business plan we've done the market
research we validated our ideas then we
might build a prototype to do a kind of
a last-minute test and then then take it
to market we propose sort of prototyping
belongs even before that we teach
prototyping the verb as a mindset and an
attitude about experimentation and in
particular using low resolution
techniques very very cheap materials
very very limited time frames to build
and test artifacts that that test your
ideas and test your suppositions
the one thing to know about this course
is it's not your typical online ed
course this course is going to require
engagement of you it's going to require
a high level of activity it's going to
require some risk-taking and it's going
to require you actually try on some of
these behaviors we're talking about but
those risks will pay off dividends for
years to come
what we've done is we've created an
experience or learning environment you
have to step into that environment it's
not a static course it's not something
we would hope you sit through and watch
the whole thing but it's something you
would see that there's a segment and
then we would sort of show you something
and the idea is that you would go off
and try it on
failures of Industry rarely come from
the wrong answers they usually come from
the wrong questions and what this course
is all about is about getting good at
asking the right questions not getting
good at answering well what we find is
if you can ask the right provocative
question you'll get two really
unexpected outcomes you're 80% of the
way there take away a feeling of the
attitudes you take on in those empathy
is a very much customer centric attitude
an attitude that I think my customer my
user is incredibly interesting I and I
really sort of want to learn as much as
I can about them at a very personal
level and and begin to make their
problems exciting and interesting for
our organization and problems that
matter and in prototyping this attitude
that experimentation is extraordinarily
valuable fun and actually potentially
something that accelerates my company
the idea that testing a few things and
and quickly running through a series of
ideas and prototyping them would
actually generate some momentum and
excitement in my organization so those
would be the things I'd hoped for
advice for somebody wants to be more
innovative is start it's not a there's
nothing to wait for there's no
particular formula one of the things we
talk a lot about with good creative work
is a bias to action and I'd say it's
sort of the one of the most important
attributes for creative people is that
they they tend to just produce more and
just be more active trying things out
embracing sort of a spirit of
experimentation I think that's really
the thing I would say is if you want to
be more creative start